some remarks to you we have presented to
President Clinton this morning the final
report of our work which details our
experiences in four and a half years of
hunting for searching locating reviewing
and releasing to the public the records
of the tragic day in Dallas of November
22nd 1963 is a voluminous file and it is
there with remarkably few redactions and
available for the American public now to
review in its entirety it we have had an
extraordinary experience as the first
group of outsiders who have had the
authority to order declassification of
government records particularly
intelligence and law enforcement records
and the president gratefully received
our report we were very happy with the
support he gave us throughout this
entire effort and it is an effort
unprecedented in American history to
have Outsiders reviewing significant and
sensitive government records and
ordering release of virtually all of
these materials
I'm Anna Nelson I'm a member of the
board and I teach history and American
University it was a great interest to me
to be on the board because I'm someone
who because of my field of study is used
to breed information a great deal and it
was very interesting to to work for once
to get documents open I think what we've
done is really enriched the historical
understanding of the period from 1961
264 when the Kennedy era basically was
in the
in the country's political center and
we've gone far beyond the assassination
itself in order to put it in some sort
of a historical context it's a very
valuable collection I want to emphasize
the fact that they have four civilians
five civilians really who were able to
declassify documents the agencies could
not stop us from looking and
declassifying if they did not agree with
us they had to come to the White House
focus the mind to have to do that why we
really were a unique body and had some
very unique experiences and we hope that
we've have prevented people in the
government that it's not dangerous to
allow records 30 35 years old to be in
the public view
I'm Kermit hall I'm dean of the college
of humanities at The Ohio State
University I really would like to send
two messages to you the first message is
that the president warmly embraced our
report spoke enthusiastically about the
need for openness in government
confirmed the wisdom of appointing the
board in the first place and underscored
the necessity of committing the United
States government to a long-term policy
of opening records to the American
people and the second is to remind all
of you that while the board is going
away today its work continues the echo
of our efforts will be heard literally
for the next decade or longer but it
also depends since some of these
documents have been postponed in their
release until the year 2017 in some
cases earlier it depends on all of us to
keep the people who are in the agencies
feet to the fire so that when those
dates come for documents to be open that
they don't shirk their legal and
constitutional responsibilities and
really the moral responsibility that's
entailed in our act actions and making
sure that the American public has the
opportunity to come to terms with the
issue of whether or not its own
government participated in the murder of
the President of the United States back
in back in the early 1960s so I would
urge all of you as well as the as time
goes by here to remember that the legacy
we present to you is the legacy of
openness and accountability in
government and it needs to be sustained
over time no matter how difficult
circumstances may become
my name is Bill Joyce I'm an associate
university librarian in the princeton
university library today is our last day
after four and a half years of effort to
form a research collection at the
National Archives that is still growing
and has now attained the size of over
four million pages this material not
only sheds light on the assassination
but on the entire period that is to say
the context of the Cold War is
illuminated in unprecedented detail as
is the inner working of the government
in a very tumultuous period in our
history this collection will be years in
the mining by researchers and it will
take a very long time to augment
understanding and to develop new more
informed interpretations of what the
importance of the period and the events
that occurred during it another part of
our work and the legacy one of the more
important of our legacies is the
precedent of what we have done is five
outside Pat board members charged for
the first time in American history to
release records of the federal
government that were previously
restricted we have developed procedures
and policies that might be applied to
other important issues other
controversies that have arisen in terms
of government behavior and we hope that
the policies and procedures that we have
developed might be applied and adapted
whenever necessary to help razoo resolve
these controversies and at the same time
to increase openness in government and
as Kermit hoja said to make government
officials as accountable as possible and
it's up to us to keep the pressure on
now that the board has gone out of
business to see to it that the
obligations that have been undertaken
and the promises to release records are
fulfilled thank you
any questions for us this morning yes go
ahead
it's the right
we have to remember that this event
occurred during the height of the Cold
War and for that reason all records
virtually on this event were sealed all
the CIA's records were sealed the FBI
records were sealed many for for many
many decades into the future there was a
penchant for secrecy a desire to close
everything off in the name of national
security when the board reviewed these
records and applied its balanced
judgment we found little reason to
continue to protect these records in
fact many of them we found really should
not have been protected during the
1960's but we do have to remember the
era in which this occurred an era which
national security concerns were
heightened and caused the ceiling of all
of these important files based on the
materials that you have seen have you
been able to draw any conclusions about
who killed President Kennedy
well I have to say first that our
mandate was to to find the records
wherever they were so to the extent this
was an investigation it was an
investigation into where the records of
the Kennedy assassination were and we
found records in every nook and cranny
of the federal government and many
records in private hands we did not find
at least in my view records which which
conclusively proved either that lee
harvey oswald was the lone gunman or
that there was any particular conspiracy
involved the records do however document
the CIA is extensive search to see
whether there were links to Cuba or the
Soviet Union they also document the
FBI's extensive search to see whether
there were links to organized crime they
provide tantalizing hints in those
directions but in my view are nothing
conclusive to shake the foundations of
the original series check let me if I
could just add something to this if I
may I think it's worth worth remembering
that we've had over 500 books written on
the subject of the assassination of
President Kennedy all of that work was
done without the benefit of
approximately 5 million records of which
have been released in the space of the
last two and a half years III think that
all ought to make is very sober about
more extravagant explanations of the
assassination in any case what will
occur now is the opportunity for people
no matter what their views are to come
to the materials in an honest and
approachable way and for critics to
really exchange news the other is worth
noting in this regard is that the board
made a valiant effort to secure records
from Belarus and also from the former
Soviet Union now Moscow we know jack and
I and our former executive director went
to Belarus we went to Minsk we met with
the KGB we saw the records they have is
about a stack of about five feet we
weren't able to get those records out
our relationship with the Belarusian
govern
the moment is not the best and hasn't
been the best but more fundamentally
those materials we believe are really
essential to understanding Oswald and
his his life really two years in in
mince was intensively followed under
surveillance the most personal intimate
details of his life were contained in
those records and we would hope over
time that the Belarusian government and
our state Department of National
Archives are somebody can work out a
deal to get copies of those in the
National Archives we also know and we
feel very strongly there are additional
materials that are held in moscow and we
would hope again that through some
efforts we would be able to get those
materials and into our work as well we
didn't have quite I think the level of
success we would have liked to have had
and working within the apartment of
state but I know that over time that
they'll give an even greater effort to
to helping us in that regard one of the
one of the problems that arose with the
investigations answer some questions
there is that each time a group
investigated Warren Commission the House
Select Committee on the there was a
Rockefeller Commission the church study
the Frank church is committing all of
these investigations then took their
records and hid them put them away close
the door on them so that in addition to
the general suspicion of the agencies
was a general suspicion of all the
investigations and these needed to be
released and that's something else I
fact our statute required that we look
at each and every one of them and
release them for the most part we have
we obviously protect the names of people
who
might be in jeopardy in various small
things like that but I think that was a
very important part of the suspicion the
fact that nobody ever investigated and
then let anybody ever see the records
they used to investigate are you saying
the Warren Commission did you have and
have all the information no the Warren
thorne Commission had only 18 months and
they took what was given to them they
took the records of CI he brought them
and they took the records the FBI
brought them and they concluded they
were asked to conclude very quickly they
were asked to conclude so that the
country could settle down there was a
lot of we know now from records in the
Lyndon Johnson library in other places
that there was a great concern that this
might there might be some element of
inclusion than part of the Communists
for example so the idea was to quickly
get it over with and they moved very
quickly in 18 months wasn't quite enough
time to go out and do their own kind of
Investigation
I think the next step I think we'd all
agree is for people to use that
collection it is very very well if
there's a database it's the first
collection the National Archives it has
such a wonderful database so it can be
searched it can be searched on the net
and if people will use the collection
and we'll start putting all the pieces
together conspirators generally don't
write it down but you can create a
mosaic you can create from these records
hopefully as Kermit Hall said a sense of
what really happened rather than
speculation of what might have happened
and and I think we all agree that we
hope that some of the records that we
have noted should be released in five
years some in 10 years should be
monitored to make sure that them out and
that people should look very closely to
keep that mentality of openness around
I think I just like to add that I think
it's important to record that the board
concluded its work we reviewed the
records that we were able to identify we
survey the agencies very carefully we
were able to review all of the records
of the various government investigations
so from that standpoint I think we can
say that our work has been concluded in
that respect however there are still
likelihood that they may be yet
additional records that may have been
misfiled they may have been misplaced
they may have been misunderstood there
are in addition to that records that
were redacted that for which the
redactions ought to come off sometime
between now and the year twenty
seventeen when all of the records are
released and we want to know that there
is an advocate now that we are going out
of business that there can be continuing
attention to make sure that that
information is released as it's
scheduled to be I think with just a
quick follow-up what will what will go
on now is the extensive work of going
through these files by individuals who
are qualified to review them carefully
and make conclusions from them I think
that our legacy hopefully will also be
that through this you new and unique
method of reviewing records and ordering
release that maybe we will taught some
of these government agencies that it is
better to be open than secret in many
cases and that perhaps some more trust
can be restored to a public that is is
weary of lies that government made
in the past so that one of the key
findings of your committee was that
there needs to be more openness in
government and you said the president
endorsed that today do you see any irony
the fact that you're meeting with the
president took place in secret well no I
don't see any irony in that you know the
president graciously made some time
available on our schedule because he
wanted to hear about our report I know
he's got a busy schedule today and what
we have tried to do as much of our work
and open as possible we've conveyed to
you really everything that was said by
the president and his strong endorsement
over our report did the president
indicate that he might be helpful in
trying to pry some of these documents
that might still be
withheld from these agencies III think
he certainly is interested in in helping
get release of the foreign government
files that we've been trying to find the
issue was at for a while on his agenda
with President Yeltsin earlier this
month but conditions there really made
that request impossible at this time he
does he is very supportive of the
opening of these records his executive
order demonstrates that on declassifying
records the more than 25 years old and
he indicated he would continue the push
for opening the records of the federal
government I just wanted to say that the
records of the board itself constitute
over 300 cubic feet of material and
there was a great deal of information
that up until now the investigations of
the assassination have been secret those
records were classified they were put
away our records are out and available
for the public in addition to the
collection and people can evaluate our
effort and see just what we've done and
make their evaluations accordingly and I
would hope that all of you who the next
time a story comes about the
assassination have the good sense to
realize there now more than four million
documents dealing with it that relates
to some of the most secret activities of
the government of the United States as
they figured in the assassination and
not let yourself be pushed around by
people who have very complex and very
exciting ideas about the assassination
that may not necessarily have those
rooted in the most current and most
valuable materials that have been
released with regard to the
assassination